the election it's coming it's here
the results are going to come in slowly
i think it'll be probably a wee a month
could be a weeks who knows for everybody
they got to get the mail-ins
the email in some people traveled back
in time and wrote who they voted for on
on a cave wall and they got to use they
got to go back in time and do
that they got to use the ouija board and
see who everybody voted for
from the 1700s you know they got
people doing all kinds of people some
people paying money have them have the
plane right in the sky
joey donny who have you know they a lot
of tablets are going to happen
they got to tablature all the votes
and then we'll know and there's some
people they think oh it's going you know
everybody they're gonna people gonna go
crazy
they're gonna be people you know paul
bunyan is gonna go through the streets
people's you know they're boarding up
beverly hills
people just you know i guess if look if
you want to go if you want to go hard
it's a good day to go hard
like you know maybe it's if that day if
you want to get out and steal some
sandals
and throw a damn you know a wheelchair
through a panera bread window
get out there and live your life sucka
okay if you want to set a baskin robbins
on fire
and you know a kickstarter batch of
grilled rocky road get out there
and be somebody
you know people say in catastrophe oh
the volcano is going to go off
you know that you know people's going to
be lighting volcanoes
people saying oh be careful you know
guns are going to be shooting themselves
it's going to be a crazy day
and i don't i don't believe that
i believe that the the hype all the bs
from the election
and the and the and the dew lolly all of
that is done
it's kind of hacky now it's been done
you're going to go out there and spray
paint on a building oh
what kind of rerun [ __ ] is that you're
going to have to people have to
you have to chain up the ante or do
nothing
i believe it's gonna just gonna be
passive
i just believe that it's been it's all
you know it's already all been done
you know i just um i don't know i think
it'll take a while to get the results
for the election
um and i think it's
you know it's normal you know it's
pretty normal the way it'll
the way it always goes the election
always happens this time it feels like
though that everybody is and i don't
know if people if everybody is really
bought in more
but they say in it
the most the most early ballots ever
cast
but that's because everybody nobody
nobody has anything to do
you know a lot of people aren't working
people can cast their ballots early
you know the poll places have been open
usually they're open on one day now
they're open you know
a couple of weeks or whatever it is
so you can have the early voting
some people know a decision early
you know some people don't know a
decision real early man
but it's uh it's kind of like a little
bit of a super bowl it'll be fun
you know i always find election night is
kind of it's a fun night it's fun to
watch and see it all kind of come in
and um and see how it shakes out
you know uh i think that trump will win
the election i just think that i
people say who do you think will win i
think he will win
the incumbent i think it's called let me
look it up
income bent
uh currently holding office the
incumbent
usually wins that second term
i think george w bush was the last
fellow that couldn't handle
that couldn't handle it all and so they
you know they belted him out but
the incumbent usually wins so
did i bet a couple grand that trump
would win
yes i did yes i did
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah